hello everyone and welcome to my king's
gambit kings course
so
i would like to congratulate you you
finally reached the final boss the most
unpleasant move each xf4
let's get going
uh first of all first of all
this is the most principled move because
can go the guy gives away a pawn so why
not just to grab it yeah for free
and uh yes it's
it's really really difficult to prove
that uh white is okay here
i really
i would say i really struggle to find
some
some normal lines
uh
to make the game work
and of course uh
all our problems they begin here then
our pawn is taken
so first of all uh we have
some choice here yeah
uh there is like uh bishop c form of uh
d4 move knight c3 move there is even uh
but don't have to too loud even h4 move
used to be played here
uh probably
not recently but uh
it's one of the one of the gambits but
i'd like to suggest you to play
the ninth game uh king's night game but
it's the move for knight f3
uh in my opinion this move is the most
logical and uh well first of all we
develop our keys and also we protect h4
from uh
this very unpleasant check and
i think uh we should start with the move
g5
no g5
uh this is said to be this is thought to
be
you know
where the official reputation or
something at least
uh you know in my
according to my uh really poor knowledge
yeah
probably before i was uh i started
making this course i thought like okay
g5 is something
uh the black should know some some lines
here but in general black is doing super
fine and g5 is the way to play against
the king's gambit
uh but somehow
i believe that white has a way uh
let's say a way out here
and uh in general it's not like white is
fighting only for the draw it's it's
very interesting
and i think the way uh to play here for
white is
h4 h4 is
you know
the most uh
a natural move at some point so we
have
a target to attack and we start
immediately by
undermining this pawn structure
fighting for some space advantage here
and of course taking they were taking
away h4 square poke from the queen
uh yes so this is
already
already covered by our rook
you can also you know time to time
especially in blizz games you can try to
gamble with
i would say bishop c4 move here or maybe
d4
but in general uh
you know i think sooner or later
uh
your opponents would show like the the
right continuation and uh
sooner or later like just extinguishes
our initiative and
starts uh you know collecting uh
material or they have uh if they already
have some material then
[Music]
okay our
our destiny is uh
uh
it's not that easy yeah let's see
so uh let's go with the h4 move
here basically
two normal moves uh
exists
uh i don't even want to speak about gtx
h4 it's just
it looks ugly so it doesn't deserve our
time we just go for g4 and something
so the main move is of course g4 but
there is
a rare continuation g5
and d5 would be
nearly killing blow
uh because i mean okay
this g5 h4 uh inclusion is just
fine for all these
[ __ ] bear counter gaming positions uh
but somehow we can play g4 and this is
very nice
uh
d4 so now we wait for dtake c4 and only
now we take on g5
that's our plan
knight f6
knight c3
somehow this move is also important so
we attack on e4
at the moment uh bishop c4 uh is somehow
not so good
just uh you know just trust me
uh bishop b4 is the move and now bishop
takes f4
so the trick is after bishop c4 here for
example black has bishop g4 a very
strong intermezzo
and white is basically
in a big trouble
so after bishop before we take on f4 uh
h6 and uh seems like uh we got to
retreat with our knight to h3 but uh as
they say not today today we go for
bishop c4
and this is very nice
i bet if uh
in a practical game uh white
would be even a slight favorite
especially if black sees this at the
first time
so h takes g5 bishop six g5
and now
well uh i mean of course i can annotate
each and every engine move but
i believe uh almost no games uh or maybe
no no
no games at all
uh have uh you know has been played in
this line with this move order
now so just for example i just show you
a few lines here so for example bishop
takes c3
takes and queen d6 it may go like uh
just to maybe to prevent knight b5 star
after castle on knight d5
uh but here okay uh white plays queen e1
and it's really hard for for black to
find
find the balance and stabilize so maybe
maybe you can try a fight but after g4
this is
just completely wild position
so the problem with f5 move that now we
don't have uh e6 square for our bishop
anymore
so that's why this move is at least
questionable
uh knight c6 queen take c4 and bishop d6
is maybe you know
a good attempt to
minimize the risk
and well wise can just play on here with
some moves like i don't know like rook
five i believe and then okay to f1
but at the same time if you
think there is
a right moment to
find a way out you just go for i mean
even rookie five deserves
uh to be here
uh in our in our file
but uh
i would say that
23 is a nice way to force a draw king d7
so this is logical and we just take here
queen g5 and we starting start breaking
through
so probably queen takes c4 is the move
uh we played d5 another
a tactical brilliancy and in case if
black takes we just take take and look
at one
so
the bishop is uh clearly under attack
and c4 is one of our ideas so k6 is
necessary and now there is a nice move
for g4 which basically forces the
repetition
so our next move is rocket arroga 6
check and then back
and i don't see if black can really do
anything about it so ruby g8 for example
check and check
and i don't think we
even need to take on d5 because
in that case position become becomes a
little bit shaky but just keep on giving
checks and okay that's a joke
well another move with knight c6 uh here
instead of knight intel bishop takes c3
also a logical one
so here we go probably for the queenside
castle queen d2
uh bishop e7 uh just uh trying to
retreat uh and to protect
our knight
castles 95 for example
and
yep it's not so clear if we are going
somewhere but there is another trick
like bishop b5 check c6 and d5
looks very nice to be honest
takes d6
and well as usual this ends in
an unclear position after knight c4 we
calmly play queen e1
and after knight takes d6 we suddenly
take here and take here
and this turns out to be not that simple
for black hotel
so probably black has to sacrifice a
queen takes
check
on bishop e7 and for example rookie one
queen takes b7
takes here and g3
so this
will most likely be a draw but
you know i think uh black is
probably need to be
slightly more precise because white has
a lot of phones and if for example white
managed to collect j7 pawn
you know these three connected passive
pawns
could be quite something yeah but i mean
of course not while our pawns on the
second rank
uh but uh again if uh black plays
scarcely
uh this game
can end in you know in white's favor uh
but to us for white i think white always
has sort of the way out because king can
never find
enough balls to protect you know his
majesty from a perpetual check
you